HOSPITALIZATIONS AND JUST HOW
MANY LIVES WERE ACTUALLY SAVED
BY THE COVID VACCINE.
THAT'S ALL COMING UP.
BACK TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND
HOSPITALS ARE STRUGGLING RIGHT
NOW ACROSS THIS COUNTRY IN
WHAT'S BECOME KNOWN AS THE
TRIPLEDEMIC, LEAVING SO MANY
PEOPLE SICK.
THE BIG THREE IN THIS CASE,
COVID-19, RSV AND THE FLU.
STATES LIKE NEW YORK, WASHINGTON
AND NEW MEXICO CHLOE TO TAP OUT
IN TERMS OF HOSPITAL BEDS
AVAILABLE.
STEPHANIE ELAM REPORTS FROM LOS
ANGELES.
>> FOR A WHILE REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT COVID.
>> Reporter: ANDERS HAD GOOD
REASON TO WORRY AFTER AN AORTIC
AN YEWISM LAST YEAR IN THE THICK
OF THE PANDEMIC.
>> OPEN CHEST SURGERY.
>> Reporter: MASKED UP, NEVER
CAUGHT COVID UNTIL THIS MONTH, I
DIDN'T FEEL I WAS INVINCIBLE, I
THOUGHT INEVITABLE I WOULD GET
IT.
>> Reporter: HE THINKS HE CAUGHT
IT AT AN NFL FOOTBALL GAME WHERE
HE LET HIS GUARD DOWN.
>> SHOOT.
FORGOT MY MASK.
>> Reporter: IMPORTANT ISLY HE'S
RECOVERING AT HOME.
>> AN UNPRECEDENTED EXPERIENCE.
>> Reporter: ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SCENES SIMILAR TO THIS.
OVERFLOW HEALTH CARE WORKERS
STRUGGLING TO CATCH THEIR BREATH
AS HOSPITALS FILL WITH SICK
PATIENTS BATTLING A TRIFECTA OF
RESPIRATORY VIRUSES.
COVID, RSV AND THE FLU.
>> WE'VE SEEN A REAL INCREASE IN
CASES PARTICULARLY SINCE
THANKSGIVING.
SO COVID IS UP, FLU IS UP AND
OTHER RESPIRATORY VIRUSES ARE UP
AS WELL.
>> Reporter: THE SITUATION IS SO
OVERWHELMING AT UC SAN DIEGO
HELD THEY HAD TO CREATE SPACE
USING TENTS AND PARKING LOTS TO
TRIAGE PATIENTS.
>> PATIENTED WAITING FOR
HOSPITAL BEDS AND EVEN
RECONFIGURING CONFERENCE ROOM
SPACE TO SAFELY CARE FOR
PATIENTS IN PLACES WE WOULD NOT
NORMALLY DO IT.
>> Reporter: HOSPITALS WERE FULL
ES THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC LAST
WEEK.
REACHING 80% CAPACITY, AND 8
PERCENTAGE POINT JUDGE IN TWO
WEEKS AND THE HIGHEST SINCE
JANUARY'S OMICRON SURGE.
>> IS THE TRIPLEDEMIC AS BAD AS
YOU SAW DURING THE HEIGHT OF
COVID?
>> THE ANSWER IS, NOT YET.
PROBABLY MOST RSV SEEN IN THE
PAST DECADE, REALLY OCTOBER INTO
NOVEMBER, AND NOW WE'VE SEEN A
RAPID DECLINE.
THAT AS I SAID IS OVERLAPPED
THIS COVID RISE, WHICH HAS
HAPPENED SLOWER, A LITTLE LATER,
AND THEN NOW SUPERIMPOSED BY
THIS VERY RAPID RISE IN
INFLUENZA.
>> Reporter: YES, YOU CAN GET
MORE THAN ONE OF THESE VIRUSES
AT A TIME.
>> THE MORE VIRUSES, THE MORE
INFECTIONS YOU HAVE, THE MORE,
THE HIGHER RISK OF ONE OF THEM
LEADING TO MORE SERIOUS DISEASE.
>> Reporter: MASK MANDATES
HAVEN'T RETURNED YET, BUT VIRUS
SPIKES IN NEW YORK AND SEATTLE
HAVE LED TO HEALTH DEPARTMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MASK UP
INDOORS AND IN CROWDS.
>> FEELS LIKE I'M ON THE UPSWING
NOW.
>> Reporter: AS FOR THIS MAN
SPENDING LAST DECEMBER
RECOVERING FROM HIS SURGERY HE
PLANS TO SEE HIS GRANDPARENTS
FOR THE HOLIDAYS AFTEREST
ITTING, MONITORING SYMPTOMS AND
WEARING AN N95 MASK.
>> THIS IS OUR FIRST CHRISTMAS,
YOU KNOW, NORMAL CHRISTMAS.
>> Reporter: AND HOPEFULLY NO
LESS MERRY, BUT KEEP IN MIND
HERE THAT THESE VIRUS SPIKES
REALLY ARE HAPPENING ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
ADD NEW MEXICO TO SOUNDING THE
ALARMS AT OVERWHELMING
HOSPITALS.
TO PUT IT PERSPECTIVE NEAR
BEVERLY HILLS AND HOLLYWOOD, TO
POWERHOUSE DIRECTORS SIDELINED
RECENTLY BECAUSE OF COVID.
STEVEN SPIELBERG AND JAMES
CAME